All right, folks, welcome back.
So today, we had the chairman speaking
at 2 o'clock in the afternoon.
You can see that here.
Now, I'm going to kind of work backward today.
And I'm going to talk about the one-minute chart,
work our way back out to a higher time frame.
So it's kind of like a bottom-up analysis.
So ahead of the 2 o'clock in the afternoon,
Fed chairman jaw-booting session,
we've seen this little judo swing here.
And notice that it just fell short of the morning high.
And the high comes here at 12,535 and a half.
And over here in the morning session.
12,535 and 3 quarters.
So it fell 1 quarter of a point, or one tick,
short of that high.
So it runs up after clearing relative equal highs,
then breaks lower, no model, short in here.
Then the market drops once more below relative equal lows.
Now, what are these lows here?
These are the lows in lunch hour.
Here's noon to 1.
And I taught you in the mentorship
that many times when there's an afternoon
continuation to the upside, you'll
see that the lows at lunchtime will get swept.
And we're seeing that here.
Now, it dug down deeper into an area,
which I did a recording for Twitter today.
And my chart didn't have this.
I thought I had it because I was looking at another monitor.
But this is the imbalance that I was looking at,
unfortunately doesn't appear in there.
But it's there, obviously.
And it's below the relative equal lows.
And the market drops down below that.
And then all of this right here was manipulation.
And there was lots of manipulation.
Initially, the market rallies up.
And what I was outlining here, at the time of the recording,
I had this actually misspelled, had it wracked.
It should be rigged as it should.
I think that's the right spelling.
I'm even questioning it again now.
But basically what's implying here
is that long holders were rigged across the coals,
not permitted to profit on the $12,553 and a quarter run.
So it starts off like it's going to go up to debt level
we were looking for, and falls short of it and breaks down.
So what's actually happening is buy stops are being triggered.
So anyone that wants to go long on bull flag patterns
and things like that, or breakout traders, they're buying.
And then they're getting taken against their long,
withdrawn out until they're either stopped out,
or if they don't have stop loss, they get squeezed out.
So they can't take it anymore, they just bail out.
Below the relative equal lows,
any long holders from the morning,
they have trailed their stop loss below here.
So they take them out, why?
Because they don't want them being able
to profit to the real move.
What was the real move?
I hinted at $12,553 and a quarter.
That was a draw on liquidity.
So we took out the New York lunch lows here.
And what I was suggesting here is short-term
about to be squeezed as it rips higher into 12,500.
Oh, that should be 553, sorry.
That's a misprint there.
You all know what that is because it's right here.
But I was being facetious while I was recording
because as I was watching it, I was watching it run up,
then it broke down.
I was like, okay, they're going to take the liquidity
out below here and dig into this imbalance,
pick up some more orders.
I got one off as far as a long at a really poor entry,
but I was really focused on just being below
these relative equal lows, that was fine.
And my stop loss here, as you'll see in the little vignette
I put on my Twitter feed.
And you can find me on Twitter at the at symbol,
capital I, underscore, A-M, underscore, V-T-H-E,
underscore, I-C-T, in other words.
So anyway, that little recording shows me getting in here
and it's below the lows.
And I was outlining how this is not a
pay rate gap to go short at and it's resistance.
Don't look at it like that.
It went up a little bit, made a little notation,
an annotation rather, that this was not resistance.
It's going to lift off from here.
And it went down to an order block, started rallying.
And I was basically outlining the internal dialogue
of those individuals that may be short from like 12,530
and their stop also be right here.
And I was kind of like saying, what would you feel
if you were short from up here, would you feel safe?
Certainly you would feel safe.
But I said, watch how that changes.
And then all of a sudden it starts running up.
And then in here, we have order block,
it trades into that multiple times, rallies up.
Fair value gap, I outlined that.
It didn't get into it,
but I was allowing for that type of movement.
And then at three o'clock,
the algorithms will start to spool price
in the direction for the liquidity,
which was that 12,553 and a quarter level,
which it hammers there.
And I'll put the business up right here.
And you'll see, well, you should be seeing.
Well, I told you my eyes are not that good.
Oh, here it is.
So about two, 12,417 and three quarters.
So just below this 20 level here,
mainly focusing on this,
because I missed the opportunity of getting in
during this little imbalance there.
So that fair value gap, I wanted to be in it there,
but unfortunately I didn't get the position on in time.
And it was over here on this candle.
So I wasn't quick enough on the draw.
So the market trades back down into the order block
and look at how it delivers with that fair value gap.
Look at that.
Beautiful delivery.
Revisits there with the order block, rallies up,
pause, sends it higher, order block sends it higher,
consolidates right below the target we've been looking for.
And then they pump it up into the area here,
12,553 and a quarter and above.
And again, the fill.
Next it's, and that's the business there.
Let's go and take some of this off.
We don't need to see this anymore.
We don't need to see that anymore.
We don't need this and don't need that.
Okay, and I'm going to take you to a five minute chart.
Okay.
Now it doesn't look so obvious in here
as to what may be available,
but we just bumped below that high early on in the morning
then broke down and all the liquidity resting above here
was treating the retail market like,
hey, you can trust us.
You know, this is resistance is not going to go up there.
And then when it starts to sell off like this,
notice that my model did not give a setup this morning
or not this morning, but this afternoon,
it didn't give this setup in here.
Even though it didn't run by side, it did sell off.
It did not give a setup.
It's important to notice that.
So some of you are fearful.
What happens if I take a trade and it's wrong?
Hopefully you see that,
now it's not like this all the time,
but you'll find that when the market's really in sync,
these algorithmic principles will not appear
in markets that are not likely to deliver as I'm showing you.
So it's not a panacea.
That means it's not going to work all the time,
but hopefully you can see that there are times
when the market does sell off,
but it doesn't give us a setup,
but then it creates the real move the other direction
where you can find my setups
and the formations of the fair value gap and such.
So obviously you can see that the market did in fact
trade down into the imbalance on that one minute chart
and it rallies from there into the 12,553 level.
We'll take that level off now.
And I want to go out to a 15 minute timeframe.
Don't want to spend too much time here.
We had an imbalance in here.
It trades down into that as well on the 15 minute timeframe.
Optimal trade entry here
and rallies up to put the bonus on liquidity.
Again, aiming for that 12,553 and a quarter
and we'll look at a 16 minute chart.
Okay, and the market trades back down into all of this here
and rallies up and this was that area
I was telling you about a week or so ago
that this is what we're looking for.
I mentioned that on my community tab,
on my YouTube channel
and we have now just pressed up into that area.
So let's go over here and do this.
And I think we'll use this one, this is the higher one.
You can see we didn't clear that out.
That's where that 12,553 level
and a quarter rather came from.
I'm not suggesting that we're making a high here
to go lower.
The next area on the upside,
it's really sloppy over here.
I would look for this one here next.
What is that high?
12,624 even.
And if we start to see that,
And if we start to really run,
we could revisit this area here,
but I'm not going so far as to say that right now,
but just look for this one here.
That's a nice one to look for on the next upside right there.
I think that's a fair one to anticipate and study.
And I think that is going to be it.
No, I'm gonna show you more time-framed daily chart.
I can't even get that to pop up.
There we go.
Routers have equal highs in here.
We ran up into that.
So that's that whole business based on the daily chart
as I was talking about in,
I don't know what episode was recently
in the mentorship on YouTube.
So hopefully you guys can see that that is in fact,
what we were working with for daily bias.
Yes, the market did in fact create a big run lower
and then create another run lower here,
but that wasn't my setup.
I was drawing everyone's attention up to that 12,553 level.
And this was the run that I liked.
And this is the one that was the hunt.
Okay, and there's that little one here and there.
So anyway, not a whole lot of money
through that paper trade.
It was like a little over $5,000
in terms of hypothetical profit, but hey, it worked.
You guys can see that the effects of it.
And it's a little bit of an advanced idea,
but I did teach about the general factors
that go behind PM or afternoon session trading.
If you're bullish and it consolidates in lunch,
find the lunch lows, wait for it to run that out
and then they'll resume.
And it's really out of the teachings
and this mentorship on this YouTube channel.
So hopefully you found this one insightful
and I'll touch base with you again
on Thursday, Lord Bill.